[Música]
vai botar meu nome é fábio vitor entrou
na casa de 20 são cidadão do mundo e
hoje vem partilhar um carinho da minha
história com vocês e confessa quando
recebi este convite van até pra ficar
falaram que ainda há possibilidade eu
não fazia me eu quero a possibilidade
então confira a minha melhor amiga
internet para nos dizer o que era muito
bem visto
segundo a segunda internet wikipedia eu
aprendi que a publicidade é capacidade
que nós temos de nos adaptarmos aquela
situação que nós enfrentamos essa
capacidade nós também o poder para
quebrar paradigmas ou seja muitas vezes
dizemos que nós temos que fazer as
coisas de uma maneira certa e
determinada forma e nós acreditamos que
podemos fazer outra maneira e nós somos
capazes de compor cidade quebrar esse
paradigma
como é que eu descobri que tinha esta
possibilidade de descobrir com
precisamente a música foi a primeira
paixão que eu tive
e como alguém que descobri uma coisa que
gosta de fazer
eu naquela altura aos 13 anos eu não
queria fazer mais nada a não ser
escrever as minhas letras só outro tempo
por dia na escola ou posto de pcs ou
mesmo porque queria escrever à noite mas
meu pai não deixava tecnologia cesa eu
não podia escrever muitas vezes
então eu tenho que arranjar uma solução
para que o que eu queria estar mesmo
fazer música então eu vou explicar como
é que eu arranjei uma solução para preço
pequeno a cidade
foi assim que eu resolvia o problema
imaginem eu estou deitado na cama e eu
quero escrever música e não vou fazer
como é que eu vou conseguir fazer desta
forma assim simplesmente eu comecei a
criar deitada na minha cama porque eu
sabia que era impossível parar e teria
que improvisar e arranjar uma solução e
após vários anos já me chama o rei da
improvisação e será que assim será que
se não eu não sei do que sou capaz mas
neste momento transformar em um adulto
quando o outrora gestão rapaz meu rapaz
não vá o braço cruzado
daqui mts não tem significado e ouvir o
pessoal está a ficar um pouco parado eu
sei que a extensão no momento isto sai
aqui embora mas não gosta do meu
trabalho na minha volta e vai embora
foi assim que eu resolvi é este problema
que é o problema
escrever né eu tenho na minha cabeça que
precisava de um papel e uma caneta ea
partir daquele momento eu descobri que
não mas não foi a descoberta do
improviso com palavras até porque houve
provavelmente não foi isso que saiu foi
tipo
o meu pai não deixa de escrever eu tô na
ca sem nada pra fazer
lamento isso mas descobri que tem a
capacidade de improvisar improvisar uma
solução para o problema que estava
estava à minha frente então eu fui
pensar e pensei
certamente esta não foi o primeiro
episódio posicionado que eu tive até
porque nós todos somos seres humanos são
gerados dentro de uma banheira e
sobrecapa fora
é um azar no entanto agora este mundo
afora
então já eu no hospital nash foi também
o ano fechado mas não esquece
minha mãe não tinha condições meu pai
não tenha abandonado
apenas não sabia que o terreno chile e
por isto resolvi só vir tratar do meu
pai iria fazer o responsável e muito
trabalhar minha tia frente para ajudar
na minha educação dando casa querendo
comida além do seu coração era apenas
temporárias em foi não sei ao certo
quanto tempo mas o meu pai vai buscar já
depois de arranjar outra mulher e é daí
que vem a própria mulher uma preciosa
que o time vai aos seis anos eu descobri
por mim pois ninguém me contou que a
minha produtora financeira natura não
compreenderam muito bem mas tudo bem
pois pra mim minha tia evinha verdadeira
mãe mas não tenha pena até porque minha
infância é cheia de presentes bons
momentos nada faltou invernos 500 roupas
foi pra isso que meu pai trabalhou mas o
dinheiro é ingrato e quando tens três
amigos quando não tem
em vez de valorizar portugal no painel
solidão você o gol o flamengo se tornou
mãe filha por um lado a imigração é
difícil quanto quem protesta forma é
complicado porque da cultura a toda hora
se homem incansável e pensar nisso é
aguentar não chegava em vão chorava
apenas quando tinha de tirar mas não
tenham pena até uma fase ruim que eu
passei que chamava a sair dólares lei
que era todas as quintas-feiras entre
última aula era física e
o golo inscrição alguém para bater mas
viu em quem quer é para mim mas não
fosse esta fase e resume a isso de uma
forma que é afinal de contas onde está a
ser capaz que eu vá atrair atrás do
bloco a escondidas nos intervalos
faltava às aulas com medo cruzá-los
digam onde é que está pois caros amigos
do clube
o fábio está aqui no pev está a provar
que não é assim tão difícil lidar com
todas as adversidades que nós temos até
então
com isso três pequenos acertos que nós
podemos ver eu tive as primeiras
mudanças de casa eu cresci logo com duas
outras famílias
eu fui habituado a chamar mãe a minha
tia ou seja e também foi obrigado a
quebrar logo vários paradigmas disseram
manhã quem da luz e não mas não é só
quem da luz e mas não é só uma mas só
uma tem chama mãe chamava irmã minha
prima ou seja desde pequeno teve
passagem das mudanças de casa pelas
mudanças de escola clipe também
provocaram ruim e essas situações todas
mas sempre escolhi militares levarem
simulou forma porque eu sabia que não
vale a pena ganhar um facto ao lado mais
negativo porque isso não ia adiantar em
nada e como ruim na altura e no
treinamento tem agora nem é coragem
principal mesmo então eu não fiz nada
para resolver ruim é e com ela aprendi
que há coisas que também se resolvem
naturalmente que há coisas que se
resolvem como tempo é eu nunca deixei de
acreditar em quem sou
e então o que é bom acaba por provocar
eu continuo no improviso e por isso que
estou aqui também hoje até que não vai
ser em cima do ano seu convidado para
tocar na lista que estava a ser
candidato à ascensão de estudantes
eu toquei e foi fantástico até altura
não havia artistas das campanhas na
seleção dos estudantes
então isso o bom é que mais tarde como
eu fui encontrando complicações
dificuldades para os artistas criam as
campanhas como eu porque nem sempre
tenhamos condições de provocar nem os
alunos sabiam que prometeu fazer porque
andavam a lei de um lado pro outro
basicamente as mesmas dificuldades que
nós tenhamos tido quando tenha sido
finalistas
eu e uma amiga juntamos de 100
não nós vamos ajudar tanto os artistas a
ter as condições necessárias como
jogamos atrás de condições necessárias
para a campanha ele que sabe surge nosso
projeto chamado e violinistas ok
neste momento estou assim minha carreira
está a vídeos no youtube conseguir subir
ao palco como sempre aqui foi e que é
pra mim uma das maiores influências dos
maiores nomes da música do panorama
musical português subia paulo pagarão
improvisos e só fui da área sem
província porque eu tenho que adaptar
também naquela via e eu só fui capaz
várias improviso porque um dia a quatro
a cinco anos antes recebia tem estado em
casa queria fazer música e não ia
conseguir vamos conseguir porque eu
resolvi então os meus vídeos já
começavam a ter milhares de views no
youtube e começava a ter muitos
conselhos e chama chamado por ser tratar
apresentem muito muito simples
estava tudo tudo é cobrir fantástica até
que em 2012 eu sou guiado por um agente
da gnr e quis logo que o problema que é
o rapper foi abordado por um agente da
gnr
o primeiro pensamento é logo alguma
coisa eu tenho que fazer
as velhinhas quando iam lá o meu quarto
e me viam um minuto teve que fazê lo
parar aqui
o intestino porque a polícia então eu
lembro na altura do ruim porque o que é
bom provar lecce e não vale a pena estar
a tentar ajudar as outras pessoas aquilo
que sou eu sei que eu sou isso aí que eu
estava no local errado à hora errada não
acredita nos preocupa porque como ruim
o vovô é se mais tarde ou mais cedo você
vai compreender que estava no local
errado à hora errada eu como tiro
aprendi uma coisa muito importante
porque eu acredito aí eu fui induzido em
coma e quando disseram que como balão
tenha ultrapassado o intestino e tenha o
respaldo nervo ciático
disseram que eu não queria mais e nunca
mais de mobilidade do joelho
o trabalho desta perna e nunca mais ia
fazer as mesmas cidades é garantir que
os cidadãos vídeos ou seja ele tem
facilitação mas já sabia dentro da minha
cabeça
o que eu tenho que fazer para ir mais
longe
eu sabia que havia a possibilidade no
corpo nem o meu destino eu tenho hoje -
entre 20 e 30 cm 130 eu continuar a
funcionar e ela votou são uma nova
realidade ea minha perna também
apesar de eu ter cãibras constante e não
são as mesmas câmeras que tenho nesta
perna mas estou aqui estou aqui falar
com vocês
ia provar que não é assim tão difícil
lidar com isto para você ver eu posso
ver é passado os vias de ter levado um
tiro e não dizer dizer à minha família
provavelmente não ia sobreviver e eu saí
do hospital há nada pra mim e fazer as
minhas próprias das cidades importantes
eu provei aos médicos que estavam e se
calhar não estavam assim tão 7 no
hospital a polícia tem uma coisa que eu
até altura eu tenho uma grande fúria
como sair não sei porquê mas tendo que
se ouvia falar em saiba que eu vi essa
última é instantaneamente
então corra saibam é o 56 vezes não a
gente não vai resultar não vou comentar
assim então eu aprendi a lidar com isso
dodô sabe aprende como sempre olha o
sangue disputa contra passar isso e
outra por sair e como leva a minha outra
profissão que é eu faço piercings ou
olímpico em uma loja de tatuagens pink
que é o senhor das pessoas
então eu quando fui convidado para
trabalhar lá era apenas como mera já não
como uma revista mas como não havia vaga
de pizza e eu já tinha passado e se essa
fobia do sangue e lingüiça e hoje soube
que o celular e o que eu quero criar as
pessoas já é eu quero provar que um
piercing não é uma coisa
obrigatoriamente mas eu sei que as
pessoas que vão à minha loja mesmo tempo
uma quebra a intenção de maia é que
acaba por ser na minha loja as redes
porque eu quero provar também que fazer
um piercing
não é assim tão difícil
então como é que o programa como é que
eu aprendi como é que eu aprendi que não
é assim tão difícil quais foram os meus
truques para lidar com tudo na minha
vida
vamos explicar aqui o marcador primeiro
troféu na rima é vendaval são aquelas
frases que nós já temos servem apenas
para ganhar tempo consegue ainda
consegue então no estilo pop surge como
se eu tiver primar por exemplo com tampa
a palavra tampa e não posso dizê-lo
tampa e tem que ganhar tempo e dizer
algo antes como por exemplo o sabe como
é que é
ou é mesmo assim ou neste momento estou
aqui então vamos por exemplo sabe como é
que é eu tô aqui com é tampa correta e
leva o segundo que é o pensamento
enviados para a equipe
o pensamento enviado é quando nós
pensamos em tampa
nós temos automaticamente duas outras
palavras que pequenos shows entre irmãos
em cantá campa tanta fantasia
então vamos usar
queremos queimar com tampa então é mesmo
assim eu estou aqui com a tampa pro sabe
como é que é
lima está em tantas correto droga
durante algum tempo mas eu vi que era
apenas suficientes não era fantástico
o contraste outro que é o de trás para
frente vocês querem ver como isto muda e
fica muito mais brilhante assim para não
deixar aqui tampa
então sabe como é que eu tô aqui com a
tampa então mesmo assim enquanto eu
cantar entanto sabe como é que enquanto
eu tanto sabe como é assim eu tá aqui
com tampa
uau eu fico na tampa estampa no momento
isto é fantástico
como é que eu aprendi a fazer isto seja
aprender que nós possamos o que está à
frente ou atrás ainda nós vamos
conseguir resolver de uma forma ainda
mais eficaz ea outro troca ainda que é
palavra proibida que quando eu em vez de
dizer tampa tem que arranjar outras
palavras a dizer
seja ela cobertura batedor ou o que eu
quiser pode ser um sinal nem pode ser
que eu quiser
está tudo muito difícil mas como é que
nós vamos dissipar a nossa vida com como
é que nós vamos deixar essa vida faça
temos um problema o problema está aqui à
frente bergala instantaneamente ganhar
tempo para respirar e pensar sobre o
problema
nós sabemos que se temos logo pensamento
enviado jogos duas outras soluções para
resolver o problema mas sabemos que se
jogarmos assim é é apenas suficiente não
vamos resolver de uma forma eficaz
então muitas vezes nós temos passado não
sabemos qual é o problema
o problema é não mudaram os dois pneus
do carro que furamos um pneu mas não
vamos poder mudar os pneus a lei então o
pensamento imediato desde que nós temos
que mudar o pneu sozinhos e depois temos
que o mecânico
depois temos a palavra proibida porque a
vez em que nós temos realmente qual é a
solução e ainda assim não nos é possível
ouvir um por um por dinheiro ou por
várias razões não é possível então isto
é vamos arranjar várias soluções que
estou aqui dizer é que nós todos temos
necessidades nós todos temos momentos
menos bons da nossa vida e nós todos
temos a possibilidade de nos mudar para
arranjar uma solução
o que nós temos que fazer o que eu
acredito que nós vamos fazer porque eu
faço assim é sempre tivemos um episódio
vestes nós vamos montar mas vou dar de
uma forma positiva
ok porque nós podemos influenciar alguém
no futuro
costuma se dizer que nós não precisamos
pensar os problemas dos outros para
aprendermos também ok
com mais ou menos adversidades que eu
não tenha suas e eu sou o vitória e
estou aqui provar que não é assim tão
difícil
ok muito obrigada até uma próxima
estamos bem estamos nós estamos online
estamos bem não estamos banha palma até
agora porque eu quero gozar eu quero ir
embora
sabe como é que é e seleção que não é
seu tão difícil na improvisação isso não
é de curado não tem significado obrigado
pessoal que está a acompanhar os dados
como é que só neste resultado
neste momento a deus porque eu tenho que
passar beijinhos e obrigado e até uma
próxima tudo bom
[Aplausos]